اساطير اعتزلت اللعبه لكنها غيرت مفاهيم
كره القدم وكاله الانباء الفرنسيه نشرت
التشكيله المثاليه من اللاعبين المعتزلين
الذين سطروا تاريخا كبيرا في بطولات كاس
العالم لنبدا في مركز حراسه المرمى بكرتون
بانس صاحب التصدي الخرافي وفي خط الدفاع
كافو فرنسا
بلقب كاس العالم عام 66 بالرغم من انه لم
يحرث مرمى اي نادي كبير في مسيرته
المتواضعه الا انه اشتهر بلقب صاحب تصدى
القرن بعد ما صدر راسيه اطلقها الجوهره
بيليه عام 70 وامامه البرازيلي لا كافور
روبرتو كارلوس كافو ظهير ايمن يدافع
ويهاجم ويراوغ ثم يمرر حقق لقبين مع منتخب
بلاده عاميه 94 و 2002 اما صاحب اقوى قدم
يسرى في تاريخ اللعبه روبرتو كارلوس
فاكتفى بلقب ب 2002 وفي قلب دفاع التشكيله
المثاليه المعتزله نجد مخترع ومؤسس مركز
الليبرو القيصر فرانس بيكنج باور صاحب لقب
المونديال مع منتخب المانيا عام 74 ضد
طواحين الهولنديه
بجانبه كان فار الايطالي صاحب لقب كاس
العالم في 2006 ضد فرنسا في المباراه
الشهيره اما وسط الملعب فتمتلكه اساطير
ربما لن تتكرر زين الدين زيدان اندرياس
مارادونا وبيليه زيدان لديه رقم قياسي
بتسجيله ثلاثه اهداف في المباراه النهائيه
للبطوله
هدفان في مرمى راقص السامبا والثالث في
مرمله زوري ويشتركوا مع الكاميروني ارجونغ
في كونه اللاعب الوحيد الذي طرد مرتين في
المونديال الثانيه كانت بسبب نطح الايطالي
ماركو ماتوراتشي
وبجانب زيدان يقف بيليه الجوهره السمراء
على راس لائحه هؤلاء الاساطير فهو اللاعب
الوحيد المتوج بلقب كاس العالم ثلاث مرات
اما صاحب اللمسه من يده وليست من اقدامه
صاحب اللقطه الاشهر في مونديال 86
مارادونا الذي اهدى بلاده لقب كاس العالم
بعد تفوق على المانيا الغربيه بثلاثه
اهداف مقابل هدفين ولا ننسى الرسام
الاسبانيه ان يستظن تشكيله الاساطير
المعتزله ومن امامه في خط الهجوم
ورونالدو البرازيلي
16 هدفا في بطولات مختلفه من 2002 الى
خطا نصف النهائي اربع مرات واتمكن من
الفوز بمونديال 2014 تفوق على زميله
بتشكيله الاساطير البرازيلي رونالدو صاحب
ال 15 هدفا رونالدو وجماعه منتخب بلاده
بلقب كاس العالم
2002 عندما احرج الالمان وسجل في مرمى
اوليفر كام
[موسيقى]